tu sais que les gens adorent ça, c'est bon pour
toi, n'est-ce pas, mais celui-ci a l'air de
me donner un coup de pouce. Y a-t-il
un Jim Wang ici,
et bien, c'est Wayne Chang waitan, c'est un
nouvel étudiant et il est chinois comme toi,
il va suivre tous tes étudiants.
cours de mathématiques
il est bien en avance sur toi en mathématiques je
veux juste être un gars ordinaire qui fait des
trucs réguliers tu t'es fait un nouvel ami
je pensais juste que cette année allait être
différente
je pourrais peut-être aider
ce qui se passe je ne suis pas de là  monde,
j'ai besoin de votre aide dans ma quête pour arrêter
le soulèvement,
la porte entre la Terre et le Ciel
s'ouvre, ok, ok,
vous devez l'arrêter, sinon tout le monde périra,
le sort de votre monde est en jeu.
Je ne vois pas vraiment comment je m'intègre
dans tout cela.  tout ça de mon guide,
laissez-moi parler de quelque chose d'un peu
plus cool que le serviteur du guide ouais, je sais que
vous avez raison, les gars, mieux
[Musique]
ce sera difficile et dangereux et
si je ne le suis pas, même si le
destin ne se décide pas là-haut mais en bas
ici, c'est
tellement incroyable
[Musique]
tout est plus connecté que tu ne le
penses,
ouais